Now recall from a previous lesson where we actually looked at
the whole concept of how we can differentiate an image in x and y, and
use that to be able to compute, for example, a derivative of an image in x,
which is basically looking at how the columns, when I parse through this,
can give me highlights, or where the maximal change is, and
in this it detects, for example, the edges here in this rectangle, and
of course, I could do the same, going row-wise in this instance, and we're
going columns in this one, and we can use that now look for maximum change,
this one then from black to white, and in this one, of course, white to black.
This shows you very nicely where the edges, or at least with
of gradient change is that we can actually use to compute things like edges.
This was also showcasing a much nicer example, of looking at how we can do with
the zebra, and here you can notice that you see, basically, information on how
the gradients that is how rapid the change is as I traverse in this direction,
and, also, if I traverse in this direction, so, in the columns and
in the rows, x and y.
Basic concept that we now want to build on to be able to do much more with.